Instagram says it will let users
download everything they've ever shared
on the platform that includes photos
videos messages and stories they've
archived the change brings instagrams
data policies in line with parent
company Facebook while Facebook has been
sharply criticized over privacy
Instagram has largely avoided
controversy tonita copal is at the
Golden Gate Bridge in San Francisco it's
said to be one of the most Instagram
places in the world tawny not a bad live
shot at all good morning yeah a little
cold but not too bad Instagram in recent
years has grown beyond pretty photos
like this one not bad to become the
second largest social media platform in
America but although Facebook yes
Facebook is behind that growth most
people don't know they're the same
company and that is no accident what do
you like about Instagram I like seeing
pictures of like the the creators that I
follow college student Jessica Laura
told us she's a daily Instagram user
following artists and feeds she enjoys
but watch what happens when she finds
out who owns Instagram would you be
surprised to learn that its Facebook is
it really yeah oh my god why do you say
oh my god because I've been hearing
about Mark Zuckerberg and a lot of
people are calling it slimy people oh
really
yeah Laura is not the only one confused
and potentially uneasy about Instagram
almost 57% of Americans don't know that
Facebook owns Instagram and TechCrunch
editor-at-large Josh Constance says
that's the way Facebook likes it
Facebook purposely tries to keep the
Instagram brand as separate as possible
they even operate a separate office
there's no facebook branding in the
Instagram app you really have to be a
savvy tech insider to get that how
important is Instagram to the future of
Facebook Instagram really is the life
raft for Facebook no matter what happens
to the Facebook brand
Instagram will be there to pick up the
pieces as users flee Facebook because
their parents are on it or they're sick
of the boring old 14-year old news feed
they can hop on Instagram and still have
fun last year Facebook lost almost three
million users under the age of 25 and
for the first
I posted a net decline of 700,000 users
in North America this year the under 25
crowd is projected to shrink again on
Facebook but keep growing on Instagram
every social network has a half-life
eventually parents get on it
grandparents get on your boss gets on it
and you don't want to hang out with them
but what if young Instagram users decide
they don't want to hang with Mark
Zuckerberg either that's a decision
Jessica Laura is now weighing for
herself does the fact that Instagram is
owned by Facebook changed now your
opinion of Instagram yeah it means
they're probably following me just like
they do on Facebook I don't like my
privacy invaded so Instagram was an
escape from Facebook yeah and now and
now I can't seem to escape anything
Instagram and if statement Alice says
that they will never sell users photos
videos or data so far the delete
Facebook movement has not morphed into a
delete Instagram movement delete
Facebook advocates like share and Rosie
O'Donnell still have active and verified
Instagram accounts Nora
Instagram is quite popular yeah Tony
thank you so much